welcome to this video I'm playing
Casanova from the US 229 they will know
2283 that tirage defense hmm let's
remember didn't they gay gifty takes you
five as interesting hmm I'm sorry and my
day form I really forgot the details
this was supposed to be interesting for
for white yeah and this some irie cannot
remember and this wasn't working but why
exactly i'm not sure okay um III or
maybe five is still be five or still a
problem now I shouldn't have played this
line I really here as I just don't know
how it works I know that this is not
supposed to be good for black the
sacrifice but I forgot why came some
maybe this is a mistake it looks very
shaky in this check on before I'd be
five as a potential move b5 Bishop takes
me five Queen 85 check lose in the PGA
yep damn ok it takes only three here my
take with the pawn it's very ugly on the
other hand if I'm not exploding
immediately or its method stopped
falling apart immediately then I'm in
good shape of course with the next
reform
yep
yeah just recap sure why not
yeah all this is probably not to
advisable for what I don't know but yeah
what is six what exactly is flex
compensation the spawn only three is
weak but it's them it takes two ball and
if he castles I take before I thought
I'd take perform
hmm yeah but it's not so it's not
entirely tinium yeah but okay it must be
right must be right oh this is some
surprising thought it we thought black
would take first but now I understand if
I capture this night situ threatened mmm
yeah then this wasn't a great idea
hmm
ja I don't I don't know okay let's take
it down after that I need to cover he on
c2
hey Roxy one night a two-night be 6 mm
yeah but it's not not great at all but
after the capture I could I could think
about rob c 70 CE six Roxy's six maybe
what I try to do is get the b6 pawn
under favorable circumstances Roxy six
maybe but he's got Bishop d7 Knight b6
night see one night a eight night xp3 is
just nothing okay so let's um go ahead
him maybe maybe he can play night before
not before we could be six and then some
check on c2 i have like ass blackest
certainly all right he's very active
very active
and if I hoped for something with the
Bishop c4 but it's not really that's not
really on
hmm should be five this rock before
and 93
yeah it's not a great position I'm
suffering with this wiki porn I don't
get I don't have enough activity here
I'm i would have needed to just to win
the b6 bowl just exchanging the
queenside it's not enough is somewhat
doesn't exchange on a sec okay or as the
rook do you want is the same mate I
don't it's a mate I am Wow okay look the
one and 94 mate I'm made into moose
if it takes now and look I ate check
yeah the storm still here this
irritating is okay one check time
morning
yeah now I'm fine again besides the fact
that I'm on 12 seconds the position is
okay now
yes no absolutely no way to to to make
the time control check check check
mmm down one second so this is your
chance wait four hits on time yeah just
just too slow yeah I lost too much time
in the opening phase where I was some
not it was quite okay here but I simply
never really a caught up on the clock
thought maybe I'm active enough to to
win the b6 pawn but it didn't it didn't
work out it is just just too much I what
I did I did a completely underestimated
this night takes before he thought he
needed to take on be one in this is this
is already quite quite uncomfortable I
probably don't have anything better than
what happened in the game and black
maybe had ways to improve here Knight c3
here wins Bob damn it was it was just a
bad bad position check yeah of course
here this is what I didn't understand
like this is this is like a very easy
winning it's just too much look at this
content and over yeah it's just too
active this whole line is some is quite
interesting for widened this is what you
played is this is not good but i don't i
don't know how it is played Bishop d2 d3
I I don't know I simply don't know um I
forgot forgot the lines here I should
have played some main line that actually
no better alright thanks for watching